[Music]
do it pretty fast do it I don't know
that I could do that the ladies of a bad
mom's Christmas finding out what's in
the box for Vanity Fair um that's a
little crazy I'd like to see you play
that not a shot okay but Cameron
actually spent a lot of time with these
ladies and clearly they are game for
anything out there and for the right
price that includes living out their cha
and sees all of the most iconic game
shows
[Applause]
hey bad mom's come on down look at how
excited you're getting from the name Jax
even I gotta tell you so much energy in
here I was freaking out good seats I was
like 14 I said that I learned English by
watching prices right like my
nine-year-old stuff was like Monday on
CBS the three bad moms are living their
dream by being spokes martyrs for the
day also some some techniques that I
witnessed firsthand showing off the
prizes it's a great prize worth teach me
some of the you had some nice reuse it
yeah
[Applause]
we're great man they've added a lot of
energy they were super fun at just the
right attitude for prices right the
audience was treated to an advanced
screening of the movie where the three
deal with all that holiday stress and
pressure and the stars like what just
happened this was incredible like so not
only having a blast doing this during
commercial breaks the three of them
would actually test themselves out on
the games and they have it finds a
girlfriend
[Music]
you
[Music]